Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies and
germs. This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to another
episode of The Tim Ferriss Show, where it is
my job to deconstruct world class performers
from all different disciplines. Could be chess,
could be military. In this case it is games,
all things gaming. My guest today is Elan Lee.
You can find them on Twitter at ElanLee. Elan
is the co-creator and chief executive officer
of Exploding Kittens. Maybe you've heard of it,
a leading gaming and entertainment
company. Under his leadership,
Exploding Kittens has expanded its portfolio
to nearly 30 different games with more than
20 million games sold in more than 50
countries since its founding in 2015.
Before founding Exploding Kittens, Lee was the
chief design officer at Xbox Entertainment Studios
where he led the interactive entertainment
portfolio. Prior to that, he was the founder
and chief creative officer of Fourth Wall Studios
and co-founder of 42 Entertainment. He began his
career at Microsoft Games Studios as a lead
designer on the original Xbox. Lee has won a
Primetime Emmy for the series Dirty Work, game
innovator of the year for Exploding Kittens,
a Peabody Award for the world's first
alternate reality game The Beast, and
an IndieCade Trailblazer Award for a distinguished
career in interactive entertainment, among others.
Elan, welcome to the show. Nice to see you.
Elan Lee: Thanks. It's really good
to see you too. Happy to be here.
Tim Ferriss: So to paint a picture for folks,
downstairs I have what should function as a
dining table, completely covered in games of
every imaginable type, and the floor is further
littered. There are dice everywhere. There are
blank dice everywhere. Cards, there are blank
cards. So I'm in the midst of immersing myself in
all things, specifically tabletop gaming. I want
to thank you because of all the games tested so
far, one game has stood out as a friend favorite,
and that is Poetry for Neanderthals. There are
people out there who will catch me on Neandertals,
and fine, I'll say it both ways for you.
Elan Lee: Yeah, we asked for that
one naming that. Fair enough.
Tim Ferriss: Where I'm hoping we could start
because I've listened to quite a few interviews
with you and there are other places where some
of your bio has been covered in I think a very,
very good fashion. I recommend people listen
to Think Like A Game Designer in the episode
that Justin Gary did with you as well. But why
don't we start, because I found a video online,
which was you interviewing two game designers who
worked on Hand-To-Hand Wombat. I found that short
conversation so incredibly helpful with the nitty
gritty of seeing how the sausage is made. I was
hoping that perhaps we could start with Poetry
For Neanderthals as a case study from the very
inception, and you could just walk us through it.
Elan Lee: Yeah, absolutely. So Poetry For
Neanderthals, it didn't even have a name. Of
course, no game has a name when you start, but
that one came to me from some friends. I met Jacob
and Francesca at this conference, and they came to
me and they're like, "Okay, you're the Exploding
Kittens guy. We've got this really cool idea. What
if there was a game where you had to learn a new
language and you're really bad at that language.
You're in a foreign land, everyone speaks the
language except you and you've got to try to get
by?" They said, "The way that we can simulate you
not speaking the correct language is you have the
restriction [that] every sentence you speak, every
word in that sentence, must be a single syllable
word." They give me some examples. They're like,
"Okay, so now listen, you Elan, you have to say,
I'm really hungry. I want to go to the store,
but there's a dragon at the store that's really
scary and I don't know what to do. Go."
I'm like, "Okay, okay, sure. Me want to
go get food." Immediately I realized, oh, I sound
like a caveman. That's kind of fun. You're right,
you have simulated this environment where I don't
speak the right language. We started working
together, and it took about a year of playing
around. We got another designer involved, a guy
named Brian Spence, and realized there's something
super fun here. There is a core gameplay loop.
There's something that every time people touch
it, every time they play around with it, they
start laughing. They start wanting to tell their
friends about it. But holy crap, those sentences,
they are a mouthful. We took the sentences down
to five or six words, still too much. We took him
down to three words, still too much. Took him down
to two words, still too much. We finally realized,
why are we complicating this? What if the entire
game was, get your friend to say this word using
only single syllable words? And that was it.
Once we realized that we were bringing baggage
through for no reason, the game got really simple,
really fun. My co-founder and business partner,
Matt Inman, who's the creator of The Oatmeal,
he took one look at it and said, "We're calling
this thing Poetry For Neanderthals." And suddenly
we had a game. It was really those steps in that
order that let us push that thing out the door.
Tim Ferriss: And could I just maybe give a
layman's take so people can envision what this
game looks like. So I played it with two other
friends. It was the three of us, and actually we
did a lot of trial and error. So I think we also
did some experimental work just in terms of how
to optimize for three people. But imagine that you
have one person who is the caveman or cavewoman,
they have these cards and you flip over the card
and at the top you have "Ghost," let's just say,
as an example. And that will get you one point
if you can give cues in these monosyllabic words.
Elan Lee: Only you can see that word, nobody else.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's right. Only you
can see the word. And so you might say "Dead
man," and you start — it starts to get hard
very quickly. And then if you get that right,
now you can say the word "Ghost." You're allowed
to say that. And so the three point, which is
the three point option below that might be "Ghost
town," let's just say. And there is an hourglass
that is turned over, which gives you I think it's
maybe 60 seconds to try, something like that,
to rack up as many points as possible. Usually
you do this in teams, if you break the rules and
you say something like "Casper," there's somebody
with an inflatable club, which does not hurt, who
whacks you on the head with this thing or I guess
on some other body part. And so with three guys,
adolescent at heart, even though this is designed
I think for ages seven and up, we just got hours
and hours of endless fun out of this thing.
It was so much fun because you also have these
ridiculous things that come up. My brother's
wife, so my sister-in-law was trying — she
had teeth and she said — no, no, she had "Mouth."
"Mouth" was the one-point word. And she said,
"Teeth house." And he was like, "Teeth house?"
The stuff that comes out can be really,
really funny. And it's very easy to get
up and running quickly, which is what made
this I think more attractive than some of the
other games I bought at game shops, which were
a much heavier lift on the way in.
And I want to just as a way of setting
the table, tell people part of the
reason I was excited to have you on,
and we chatted a bit before recording, and you
and I are aligned on I'm sure quite a few things,
but one is helping people, and I'll include
myself in that group to spend less time in
front of screens. And games are a very easy way to
do that if you find the right games and you choose
the right tool to suit your personality.
And those are the friends that you have.
So I jumped in and gave a TED Talk there for
a second. So thanks for putting up with that.
Elan Lee: Well, but hold on, let me just
interject. What you just described. I mean,
you're hired, that was the perfect commercial.
What you just described is a game that's not
necessarily entertaining, but a game that
allowed those three people — you included — to
entertain each other. And that's music to my
ears. That means, okay, success. We built a
cool game there. That was the goal. We hit it. I
didn't even have to be in the room to facilitate
that. You just had exactly the experience I
wanted you to have. I'm thrilled. Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: So let me dive into a few of the
stages. You met the game designers, who you named,
and what led you to want to work with them?
Because you must personally and as a company,
I would imagine get pitched a lot of new games.
Elan Lee: A lot. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What was it besides the concept,
because ideas are worth something, but they're
not worth as much as people like to think. So what
was it that led you to want to commit to working
with them and in what capacity was that? And
what happened over that year? Was it simply that
everyone had a lot of projects they were juggling
and that had to fit in the gaps or something else?
Elan Lee: So we got to take a little
bit of a look at the anatomy of a game.
What that means is I believe the most important
part of a game is I don't have a great term for
it. Actually I have no training in game
design, so I make all this stuff up along
as I go. So bear with me. But at a game school —
Tim Ferriss: I think you're doing fine in life.
Elan Lee: Thanks.
Tim Ferriss: Making
it up as you go. So keep doing what you're doing.
Elan Lee: Yeah, yeah. Will do. All right. I think
at the essence of any game is what I at least
call the core gameplay loop. And that's the
thing that you're going to do over and over and
over again. So in the case of Exploding Kittens,
the core gameplay loop is Russian roulette with a
deck of cards. There's a few bad cards in there.
Draw a card, hope it's not the bad one. You
survive to see another day. Core gameplay loop.
UNO, right? Classic game. Everybody knows UNO.
UNO, if I had to describe the core gameplay loop,
I would say it's a lock and key mechanism. And
all that means is you have a hand of cards,
everyone's a key. As soon as you play a key on top
of a lock, which is in the center of the board,
it becomes a new lock for the next player.
That's the core gameplay loop. In that case,
it's numbers and colors, but still it's just
locks and keys and playing one converts one.
So that concept of finding a core gameplay loop
that's compelling and interesting is really hard.
Really, really hard. And the ones that I'm most
attracted to when I hear them is core gameplay
loops that are not actually entertaining. Core
gameplay loops that make the people you're playing
with entertaining. Because I really think that's
at the heart of games. When I think back to my
childhood and playing games with my brothers and
sisters growing up, I don't remember any of the
games because I don't think I should remember any
of the games. The games were not important. It's
the tool set. Those games are tools for me to
have fun with my siblings. And I remember that
fun. I remember the laughter. I remember the
secret alliances. I remember all that stuff
because the games had really strong core gameplay
loops that allowed me to have those interactions.
All right, sorry, big rabbit hole there, but —
Tim Ferriss: Love rabbit holes.
Elan Lee: We'll try to keep it short. Right. Okay.
Tim Ferriss: So that's what long-form
podcasts are for.
Elan Lee: Yeah,
fair enough. All right. So the next thing. So for
Poetry, when Jacob and Francesca came to me with
this concept, I didn't think it was a good game.
Tim Ferriss: And just for clarity, were they
friends, were they out of the blue? Were they
working for the company in part-time or full-time?
Elan Lee: So this was at a conference called ORD
Camp in Chicago. It's an invite-only conference.
So very few people there. I show up, crazy
introvert, I'm scared out of my mind to talk to
people, but there's only a hundred people there.
So anybody who comes up to me and says hello,
I'm like, okay, there's something cool about
this person. Otherwise, they wouldn't be here.
Tim Ferriss: And there's nowhere
to hide. There's nowhere to hide.
Elan Lee: Yeah, there's really nowhere to
hide. So when they approached me and said,
"Hey, can we talk to you?" I just thought, I need
to give everybody here the benefit of the doubt.
I need to get over my shyness, I need to talk to
them. And it turns out it was a great idea because
what they showed me, like I said, was not a fun
game, but a really interesting core gameplay loop.
This idea that communication is easy, if
you reduce it down to monosyllabic words,
communication becomes really challenging and
you need your friend's help to get you from
that caveman talk back to regular English.
Tim Ferriss: So over that, then, year period
of time, what is happening, just to come back
to the anatomy of the development of the game.
How do you refine? Do you play test? What
is play testing, all that kind of stuff?
Elan Lee: One of the biggest assets that we
have at our company, and the thing that took
me seven years to build is this program called
the Kitty Test Pilots. And this is a group of
families that have reached out to us saying,
we love your games, tell us when the next
one comes out. And we respond, great, want to
test some prototypes for us? And we regularly
send them out very, very half baked ideas.
And we asked them just to send us feedback.
So what happened over the next year? So we took
that idea, I showed it to some friends, I said,
okay, what if you had to translate these sentences
using only single syllable words? And what came
back was, holy crap, this is cumbersome. This
is so hard and there's not enough time. And
my turn took eight minutes, and what the hell
is that? And we all this really bad feedback,
but I knew that the core gameplay loop was
really solid. So that's when we went down to,
okay, what if the sentences were only five
words long? What if we reduced the timer to
two minutes, then one minute? I think
the final is actually only 45 seconds.
Don't hold me to that. Something in that range.
Tim Ferriss: Something. Yeah.
Elan Lee: But we started to realize I'm getting
better and better results. The fewer words they
have to do at once, but they want more time to do
a bunch more words. So eventually we got down to,
all right, let's try out two things. One, you only
have to do one word at a time. Let's see if that's
interesting. And two, what does punishment
mean? Because everybody laughs when you use
a word with more than one syllable. But then
it kind of ended. It was setting up for a joke,
but the punchline never came. And so we thought,
all right, we'll put a buzzer in there. Or there's
a word you shout out, and I'm pretty sure it was
Matt with his just perfect pitch sense of humor,
said, well, it's a caveman game, so give him a
club and let them bonk each other over the head.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sure general counsel loved that.
Elan Lee: Oh man, you would not believe how
lawyers hate us. Holy crap. Endless,
endless conversations. But they made
us in the instructions, they made us say, "Hit the
other person over the head softly." They insisted
on that. And so we changed it without asking. We
put it to "soft-ish" over the head, and that was
our version of a compromise. Anyway, when we talk
about the anatomy of a game though, we're talking
about that core game play loop. Okay, we've really
got it now. One word, get through as many one word
cards as you can, as fast as you can. You've got
a few seconds to do so. And now we start to add
the surroundings around the game. We need
to pick really funny words that we know are
going to elicit funny responses. "Teeth" is
really great. "Teeth" was calculated. "Teeth"
is not just a word that shows up in that game.
We had to think, all right, what are words where
when you try to describe them, you're going
to start to stumble and the places you have
to go yield really funny results. And things
like "teeth" start to show up in the game. And
then we started thinking about punishment and we
started thinking about the “no stick” it's called
because everything in the game is just single
syllables and on and on it went until we had our
core game loop surrounded by this really beautiful
kind of menagerie of things that enhanced the
experience and made it so like, okay, you can
start playing this game. Every single element
is going to push you towards that core gameplay
loop. And the core gameplay loop is going to rely,
it's the fuel running that engine, that loop
running over and over again is the other
players. And once we hit that and this beautiful,
elegant, fast loop, that's when we start throwing
that thing in a box and pushing it out the door.
Tim Ferriss: Chipping it out. So could you give
another example or two of core gameplay
loop? Because on one hand it sounds like
there could be a core gameplay loop that is
almost like a theme much like you might have
the Hollywood pitch of say Alien, which is Jaws
in space, right? So there's something very simple
which encapsulates the melding of two ideas that
make something interesting. But it could also be a
game mechanic, which I know much less about. Could
you give another example of a core gameplay loop?
Elan Lee: I love dissecting games to find these.
So I'll start with one of my own. So let's look
at Exploding Kittens. I described it really
briefly before as just Russian roulette with
a deck of cards. That's not accurate. If we want
to talk about the actual core gameplay loop, what
that game is Russian roulette with a deck of cards
where you get to decide where to place the bullet.
And that is super important that actually
the very first time we tested the game,
it was just, here's a deck of cards, there's
a few bullets, and we didn't even know what
to call it at the time. There's a few bullets
in this deck. We're just going to take turns
drawing. Someone draws a bullet, you're dead.
Everybody continues on without you. That game
was no fun at all. And the reason it was no fun
is because it's us playing against the game.
The game has all the burden of entertaining us,
absolutely uninteresting. We introduced these
other cards into the game called defuse cards, and
all the defuse card did was it said, "Look, if you
draw that bullet instead of dying, you can put
it back in the deck anywhere you want in secret."
Now we've got a game because now it's not —
it's not actually Russian roulette. It's not
a random game. You have to survive me, you have
to outthink me. I just put this thing somewhere
in the deck and now it's your turn to go. Did
I put it on top? Maybe you don't want to draw
that card. Did I put it on the bottom? Maybe
you don't want to draw that card. Did I know
that you knew that I knew that you knew that I
didn't put it on the top and so you skipped your
turn and drew the second one down? Well, maybe
I knew that. Right? Suddenly, the game fades
away and I'm playing against you. And that's
the core gameplay loop of Exploding Kittens,
and I believe why it's been so successful.
Tim Ferriss: So we're going to bounce all over
the place, which is I guess I'm going to make it a
feature and not a bug of my style of conversation,
but let's chat if you're open to it about
Kickstarter for a moment. Because I know a
lot of people outside of games specifically will
still be interested in Kickstarter or crowdfunding
in general. So you, I believe at one point,
had a fraud alert email printed out and framed,
and I think somewhere the limit was set like
10,000 and maybe it got bumped like 50,000
for this new bank account for things.
What was your initial target for the
Kickstarter campaign and where did you end up?
Elan Lee: The initial target was we were trying
to raise $10,000 in 30 days, and we set that
alert. The bank would let us deposit a check
up to $50,000. They were being very generous,
and the check that we tried to deposit at the
end of those 30 days was almost $9 million.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Yeah. So I have specific
questions around how you did things differently
and you had some very strong advantages going
in. You had your background. You had Matt and The
Oatmeal and all the followers of The Oatmeal. So
you had a deck that was loaded in
a sense, but still ended up being,
maybe still is the most backed in terms
of number of backers, Kickstarter project,
or at least at the time that was the case.
Elan Lee: Still the case by a lot, actually. So in
order to talk about Kickstarter, we have to talk
about two things. One is alternate reality games,
and the other is The Oatmeal. So alternate reality
games, my background being sort of trained at
Microsoft and at the Xbox, and learning about
communities and the appeal of games and why we
play games together, I then went off and started
with some friends, this company to build alternate
reality games. And all you really need to know
about alternate reality games, although I could
talk about them for a long time, is the central
premise is together you are stronger. Together as
a community, you can do stuff, you can become
extraordinary versions of yourselves. And the
games are set up to deliver a story out in the
real world that is convoluted and you have to
piece it back together. It's like my mentor Jordan
Weisman likes to call it, internet archeology.
So archeology is you find all the little bits
and pieces of the vase. You put it together in
order to figure out what it is about that society,
how that society lived, how those people lived.
Alternate reality games are the same thing. We
write a beautiful story, start to finish with a
very compelling narrative, and then we break it
up into little pieces and we hide those pieces
everywhere in the real world, on the internet, on
phone lines, fax lines, live actors, everywhere.
And you the audience working together because
you're stronger together go and perform that feat
of archeology, find all the pieces, put them back
together, look at your beautiful digital vase,
and then learn the story based on what you found.
So I built a lot of those and I was really trained
over and over again, really beaten into my psyche
community first, community first. They're so much
smarter than you are. Learn to entertain
a crowd. That's what this is all about.
All right. We decided to launch this
Kickstarter campaign. We had this really
compelling hook. We knew the game was really good.
We put up the page and the very first thing that
happens is The Oatmeal goes into full effect. Matt
has spent at that point about a decade building an
audience, earning their trust, convincing them
that he does just really high-quality work.
Tim Ferriss: And for those who don't know,
could you just explain what The Oatmeal,
so at that point, what it looked like?
Elan Lee: Yeah. So at that point, The Oatmeal
was and still is a webpage, theoatmeal.com. And
Matt has spent 10 years writing short form comedy,
one panel, sometimes up to four panel
comics, sometimes very few long form comedy,
or I should say long form pieces where he tells
stories about his childhood or he — it's a lot of
social commentary and they're hilarious. They're
beautiful. Some of them have won Eisner awards.
They will make you cry. Matt is truly one of the
most talented artists and comedians I've ever met.
And yeah, he's a guy who's just so much smarter
than I am. It's an incredible collaboration. And I
got to meet him through a mutual friend. I pitched
this game to him. We talked about it. He said he'd
really like to help. And off we went. And when
we launched the Kickstarter campaign, honestly,
it was only three weeks after I met him.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. That's fast.
Elan Lee: Yeah, really fast. We built this —
Tim Ferriss: Didn't realize it was that fast.
Elan Lee: We built it fast because we had nothing
to lose. We didn't think it would be a huge
success. We just thought, this feels really good.
We don't have to overthink this. Let's just go.
Tim Ferriss: Now, is it fair to say that also at
that point you had the game mechanics refined and
Matt was bringing in a lot of the sort of artistic
comedic flare in terms of the back hair cards and
the artwork. So you're effectively adding art to
game mechanics that were ready to go, but kind of
lacked an artistic vehicle. Is that fair to say?
Elan Lee: That's totally fair. There are 56 cards
in the game. And so Matt's task was not to
design the game, although we both worked
hard to refine it. Matt's task was write 56
one-panel jokes. And he did. You flip through
that deck and the first thing you're going to do
is just laugh. I mean, it's such beautiful art.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: Okay,
so back to our story. We launched the Kickstarter
campaign and Matt posts about it. And he says,
"For the first time ever, I've done a game. I hope
you like it." And millions of people showed up,
literally millions of views to that Kickstarter
page. And we got funded, we were trying to raise
$10,000. We got funded in seven minutes. I mean,
it was out of control. And our first day we made
a million dollars and our second day we had $2
million, and our third day we had $3 million.
And it was just like, this is a runaway train. We
have certainly caught lightning in a bottle. We
have unleashed the full potential of The Oatmeal.
Here's finally a way to productize that incredible
brand. Welcome Exploding Kittens to the world. But
then after the first week, it fell off a cliff.
And the reason is just because everyone who Matt
could reach, who was interested in this thing,
had taken a look, either made a purchase decision
or not, and that was it. The tank was empty.
So I sat down with him and we're like, well, we've
got two choices. We can either just sort of ride
off into the sunset and say, we made $4 million
bucks. That's incredible. We were trying to raise
$10,000. Let's just take a bow and we're done. Or
we should try to push this thing a little bit and
just see what else is possible on Kickstarter.
At the time, the way that Kickstarter worked,
the kind of only lever you had were these things
called stretch goals. And the way a stretch goal
works is you say, "Look, I've got this product.
I'm going to charge you 20 bucks for it, and we're
going to try to raise $10,000. But if we raise
$20,000 for free, everybody gets three more bonus
cards. And if we raise $50,000, you get a carrying
case. And if we raise $100,000, gold-plated cards,
whatever it is." That was the tool you had.
"Give us more money, we'll give you more shit."
We kind of thought, there's got to be
something else we can do. There's got to
be something else. And I suddenly like my
eyes went wide and I realized, holy crap,
I've been training for this moment my whole damn
life. We need to activate the community. Instead
of thinking of this as crowdfunding, let's
think of this as CROWDfunding, right? And so
we did stretch goals just like everybody else,
but instead of tying it to money, we tied it to
just insane shit that we could ask the
backers to do. We basically said, "Look,
we're going to throw a party and everybody's
invited. Instead of giving us more money,
we're done with money. Instead, we've got this
character in our game called Tacocat, half cat,
half taco. Show us a picture of a real tacocat.
And if you do, if 10 people do that, we'll throw
in 10 extra cards." And that's a stretch goal.
"And you know what would be funny? What about give
us a picture of 10 Batmans in a hot tub, whatever
the hell that means, we want to see it. Somebody
does that, we'll give you a fancy carrying
case." And we just went nuts. We wrote these
challenges that were insane and funny, and
basically said, "We just want to have fun,
please have fun with us. This is going to
be — we're only here for another 20 days,
so why don't we just celebrate the whole way
through?" And the audience jumped at it and
they did everything we asked. They took those
pictures and they wrote poems, they filmed videos,
they went out on the streets, they met each
other, they had parties together, they ordered
pizza. All the fun stuff because we basically
said, "Money doesn't matter anymore, let's
just have fun." And it was a great invitation.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So many places I want to
go with this and of course, all of this alternate
reality training for this sudden IRL Olympics that
is brought to bear in Kickstarter.
Elan Lee: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: The first is just to put in
context the "money doesn't matter" comment,
because it seems like at the time, you were around
four and you made additional millions of dollars.
Is that because there was a pre-order button
on the page, and as buzz built, even though the
tiers weren't predicated on people spending more
money, you had more new orders coming in as the
buzz around these challenges and so on traveled?
Elan Lee: That's exactly right. We didn't ask for
more money, we just said, "This is the
page where we're going to use this page
as mission control. This is where we're
going to put out all the new challenges,
this is where we're going to tell you what you've
earned when those challenges are complete." None
of those challenges, again, have anything to do
with money. But because it's a Kickstarter page,
there's also a back this project button right
there. And so the dollars kept rolling in.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I love this because you're
doing what I think is so beautiful when it works,
and I want to ask you more about it because I'm
sure you have more thoughts, which is how do you
turn, say, casual fans into super fans, super fans
into proselytizers? And then you basically, and I
know this is simplified, but if you do that well,
you basically don't need a PR marketing department
to the extent that you would otherwise, right?
Absolutely. And now you had them doing all sorts
of stuff. So pets disguised as fighter jets, real
unicorn enchiladas, and it goes on and on and on.
The second major question that I have is, how
did you track all of this stuff? Because it
seems like, at least in today's social media
environment, perhaps it's more scattered now
and was more centralized then, but how did you
keep track of all this stuff? And I guess you
don't need to keep track of all of it because
really you're saying, "If we get 10 Batmans
in a tub and we get 10 of those, unlock."
Elan Lee: Yeah, exactly. We tracked it very,
very poorly. Look, we had a two, sort of
arguably three-person team at that point.
Tim Ferriss: What does arguably three-person mean?
Elan Lee: Yeah. Well, some friends of mine would
sort of drift in and drift
out in their spare time.
Tim Ferriss: Right, right, right.
Elan Lee: I'll tell you, I learned
something amazing. So we had a Gmail account
associated with the Kickstarter page, and —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Elan Lee: — apparently there is a limit if a
Gmail account receives a certain number of emails
over a certain number of time, a particular amount
of time, that Gmail account gets shut down.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no.
Elan Lee: It turns out that
number is 10,000 per second.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow.
Elan Lee: And we hit that trap.
Tim Ferriss: Holy shit.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So do you just assume, you're like,
"All right, we're not going to read 10,000 a
second, we assume there's some Batmans in a tub
in there, so fuck it. We were planning on being
able to deliver anyways, let's just, let's do it?"
Elan Lee: All right. So you asked the question,
how do you convert those casual fans into
super fans? The way you do that is you don't
make those assumptions. You actually do need to
read through those emails because the conversion
process is shining a light on them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally. Totally.
Elan Lee: You have to send out an update
that says, "Look what you did." And you
have to have the pictures right there.
And the first draft of that update said,
"Look what happened." And we realized, whoa,
that's the wrong message. It has to say, "Look
what you did," nothing to do with us, nothing to
do with just facts, you, you, spotlight on you.
And that's when people started to convert because
they're like, "Oh, alternate reality training,
we are more powerful together, we are a
community. Let's all keep working together."
Tim Ferriss: So you've learned a lot, and I'm
sure that the approach you take to distributing
your games has changed over time since once you
establish yourself, it's like once you're Guns
N' Roses and you've had Appetite for Destruction,
the way you approach things is a little different,
right? But I've read you elsewhere warn, which I
thought was very astute so I'll mention it here
and then I'd love for you to maybe flesh it out
a bit, warn people about stretch goals where for
instance, they're like, "We're going to give a
t-shirt," and it's like, well, wait a second,
how much experience do you have with man
manufacturing, fulfillment, SKUs, multiple
sizes? And if you have a tabletop game, it's hard
enough to learn how to be in the tabletop business
if you're new, let alone deciding you're going to
have also a t-shirt business to try to figure out,
not to mention the distraction cost.
Are there any other best practices
slash pitfalls that you would warn against?
Elan Lee: I haven't looked at the numbers
recently, but there was a time about two or three
years ago when I looked at the top 10 Kickstarter
campaigns of all time. And we're always in that
list somewhere, people are constantly beating our
record. They haven't beat our number of backers,
but certainly made more money than we have.
And I looked at the top 10, and of those 10,
we were the only company still in business.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Elan Lee: And it's because when
that much money comes in it, well, sorry, before
that much money comes in, to earn that much money,
there is this incredible temptation to branch
out and to become a t-shirt company and send out
posters and say, "We're going to hand autograph
every single instance of this thing." And it's
such a mistake. You are being backed to focus
on fulfilling one item. Just do that. Just stop
trying to give people more party favors, stop
trying to be more popular. The way you make
those friends is by fulfilling the promise
you made to those people. And it's very rare
that people adhere to that. It's such a shame.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm going to, I've just been so
excited to talk to you, man, I really appreciate
you making the time. And despite my caveat at the
beginning before we started recording, which
was, I think I'm having an allergic reaction,
I'm actually slowly pulling it together,
going from my zombification earlier to
semi-coherent. So thank you.
Elan Lee: My pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: I want to give you credit where
credit is due. There are many ways I could do
that, but top 10, to still be in the top 10 of
all time is remarkable for a lot of reasons, one
of which is as Kickstarter gains in popularity,
it is not an apples-to-apples comparison. In
the same way that if you look at, say, the top
100 box office earners of all time from a film
perspective, it's very hard to compare something
from the '50s or '60s with, say, 1990 because of
theater penetration, inflation,
right, that's a thing.
Prices go up. So it's astonishing that you
guys have had that degree of longevity. And
part of why I think you have been, and this is
speculation, but part of why I think you have
been so successful, and not just once but multiple
times, is you're very good at applying positive
constraints and so I would love to know, for
instance, as a company, right, so it's one thing
to go from a successful project to fulfilling
that project, and a lot of people are killed
just in that process, it's quite another to build
out a company that then expands, raises funding,
takes on private equity, and has done everything
that you guys have done, which is, it's very rare.
What are some of the constraints?
Because if I look at your games, right,
I look at the form factor, the size, it seems like
there's thought put into maybe the maximum size,
I don't know. And then I look at the complexity
and I'm like, okay, we're not dealing with metal
figurines. And so how do you think about
the parameters that you place on your games?
Elan Lee: Yeah. Oh, there's
so much to talk about here.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Elan Lee: One of them — all right.
Okay. You open a game box, and I'm going to
break that down into two parts, there's the game
components, and then there's the box itself. Okay.
First, let's talk about the box itself because
it's this ridiculous conundrum. If you were to go
and buy a new iPhone, that box is beautiful and
they spend 10 or 20, $50 building that hard
cardboard box and it's beautifully printed
and it's glossy. And you know what you do? You
take out the iPhone and you throw the box away.
My margins on my box are so tiny that I need to
spend four cents, five cents building that box,
and you're going to take the game out and then
you're going to play it and you're going to put
it back in that box, and that box has to survive
20 years. It's insane, it is so hard to do. And so
the first thing to talk about is the constraint.
First, we have to understand play patterns,
we have to understand how the audience actually
uses this product. And most games will spend,
they'll stay within their margins. They'll say,
"Well, we can only spend four cents on the box, so
we're going to build it, we know the thing's going
to disintegrate, but so be it." We don't have that
approach at all. We lose money on every box, and
that's cool. We're okay with that because we know
this is a lifelong commitment we're making to you.
Tim Ferriss: Now, just to be clear, when you
say box, this is the packaging surrounding
the game, you're not saying on every game.
Elan Lee: Correct.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: Correct. Exactly right. We break it down
by, there's a certain amount of budget allocated
to each component and the box is one of those.
Tim Ferriss: Component.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Now, so now let's look
at the actual components in the box,
and I had to learn about all this stuff. I had no
idea that there was such a thing as card thickness
or weight of different cardboard components. I
didn't know that there was such thing as, did
you know there's a catalog of sand timers that
you can look through? They're not all the same.
Forget how much time passes through them, but the
quality of the sand, the quality of the plastic,
does it have one layer or two layers? Are
they multiple colors? Have you dyed the sand?
All this stuff. And we look at all of it.
And for our mantra as a company is
opening that box has to be a delight. Everything
you touch in there has to feel beautiful, it has
to feel like someone loved this thing, because
we're about to ask those players for a lot. We're
about to say, "Put down your phone, holy crap,
put down your phone, read 15 minutes worth of
instructions," that's a huge ask, 15 minutes,
and explain it to everybody else at the table,
and then try playing the game and you're probably
going to screw it up and read them again and then
try it again. The dropout rate is enormous, but
if they feel like someone really cares about
this thing, someone really devoted time, maybe
it'll give us more of a chance. And so that's
the biggest constraint we place is we're like,
okay, just put the budget aside for a second,
know that what everybody else does not really
apply here. We need to make a beautiful product,
we need to make something that people fall in love
with as much as we are in love with it. And that's
the translation. Our love will equal theirs.
Tim Ferriss: So question about size,
not to get too personal.
Elan Lee: No.
Tim Ferriss: No. But so, I would imagine that
with the components, there are materials cost,
and that could be just a volume question, how
much of X material you are using. The games that
I have seen produced by Exploding Kittens have all
seemed easy to travel with. I don't know if that
is a side effect of other design principles
or if that is sort of a first principle, or
do you have games that are much larger?
Elan Lee: We do.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: We do. We've tried a bunch of things. So
when we talk about size, there's a few
things to keep in mind. Travel is huge,
we know people want to be able to transport these
things from place to place, bring it to a party,
bring it to a family reunion. That stuff is super
important. But when we put a box on a shelf,
we're fighting with all the other games on that
shelf. And if you think of a box as a billboard,
the biggest billboard's going to win. So having
a smaller box is not necessarily advantageous
there. But now let me pitch the flip side of
that, which is we've got to ship these things
from the manufacturing plant to a warehouse,
and how many boxes can you fit in a shipper?
Tim Ferriss: Fit on a yeah, on a
pallet, and then in a container.
Elan Lee: Exactly. Right. So all of that matters
a lot. So it's this very delicate balance. What
we've started doing, because we prefer smaller
boxes, we've started doing deals with retailers
like Target and Walmart to say, "Look, we're going
to give you a smaller box, but let us build..."
these are called shippers, they're
big cardboard frames that sit on the
shelf and then the game sits inside of it. So
we're trying to get the best of both worlds,
right? Big billboard, lots of presents on the
shelf, but the game is actually really small and
convenient and you can take it with you anywhere.
Tim Ferriss: Do you guys, and I should know this,
but I don't, how do your sales channels break
down? And we can edit this out if you don't
want to talk about it, but I'm curious,
in the beginning you had D2C, D2C, D2C,
right? Direct-to-consumer, you're shipping,
you're handling all of that. As you become
more popular and particularly given the ease of
use of your games, the doors open up to using
distributors and getting placement in places
like Walmart, Target, et cetera. What does
that look like now for you guys versus in the
— what did it look like for the first three or
four games, and what does it look like now?
Elan Lee: So first three or four games were
100 percent D2C. All we did was sold the game
ourself. That's what Kickstarter basically was,
right? Then we moved into Amazon, and Amazon very
quickly eclipsed our ability to sell our own game.
And then the retailers, retailers went through
this incredible shift, they're like, "Hey,
our game sections used to have four games. It used
to be like, we've got Connect Four and Monopoly,
and that's about it." And they said, "Let's
actually build a real game section." And they
reached out to us and said, "What's it going
to take to get you on the shelf?" And we said —
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Anchor tenant.
Elan Lee: Yeah, right. Seriously. I mean,
seriously, we were — talk about
right place at the right time.
Tim Ferriss: That's cool, man.
Elan Lee: Yeah, seriously.
Tim Ferriss: That's a big deal.
Elan Lee: It was huge. It was huge. And so we
got to kind of build the games departments with
them and to say, "Yeah, but you've got to teach
us everything, right? We don't even know what a
shelf is, we don't know what price to ask for, we
don't know anything." And they worked with us and
we built it together and it was really awesome.
And now I can't give you a retailer-by-retailer
breakdown, but I will say that retail accounts
for about 60 percent of our business now.
Tim Ferriss: What is the remaining 40 percent?
Elan Lee: It's a mix between online, hobby,
international, and direct to consumer.
Tim Ferriss: What is hobby?
Elan Lee: Oh, sorry. Yeah,
I had to learn this too. So there's two —
Tim Ferriss: I mean, I know the word.
Elan Lee: Yeah, yeah. Right, right. So hobby is
this generic term that covers a lot of things.
It basically means a store that primarily sells
games. So if you think of kind of mom and pop game
stores, they're typically where you're going to go
to buy more hardcore games, more strategy games.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
Elan Lee: But they're starting to
really get into party games. So they have a lot of
interest in us. But while we can sell directly to
Target and Walmart, there's hundreds of thousands
of hobby stores, so you have to work through a
middle manager to deal with those people.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, distributor of
some type or something like that.
Elan Lee: Yeah, exactly. Yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So this is going to strip away
the company for a second, because I'm curious.
Let's just say there's something like Iron Chef
for tabletop games. If you want that, you can run
with it. I'll take my customary 15 percent.
Elan Lee: Yeah, all right.
Tim Ferriss: But so it's like the unveiling
of the components, let's just say, which would
be some constraints. I'm not going to give you
specific ones, but let's just say you yourself
kind of locked in a room, like old school Japanese
manga artists, this would happen, the publishers
would be like, "You need to finish X number of
issues, we're going to keep you fed, but you're
going to be in a room until you finish," which
is very intense. But let's just say that you had
a week to design a game. You're
allowed to have some play testers
come in for the second half of the week.
Elan Lee: Okay. Generous of you. Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: You're welcome. I'm a very lenient
dictator. I'm known as the thoughtful warden.
How would you personally approach it? You can have
pen and paper and all of the mock-up materials
that you need. How would you go about it?
Elan Lee: First of all, you don't need much
more than pen and paper, honestly. That's it.
So the way I would go about it is I would say,
okay, given this, maybe these blank cards and
these sharpie pens, which I travel around with
everywhere, that is all my bag is filled with —
Tim Ferriss: And blank cards,
you mean like a playing —
Elan Lee: Yeah, like poker cards.
Tim Ferriss: — deck of cards? Yeah.
Elan Lee: But blank, white on both sides. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Where do you get those?
Elan Lee: Amazon, and I order —
Tim Ferriss: Amazon. All right.
Elan Lee: — literally, I order them
by the pallet at this point. It's nuts, because
they're so cool, right? You need to design a game,
you've got the cards. You need dice, I don't have
dice, great, I'll take six cards, right? One, two,
three, four, five, six, shuffle them up,
draw a card, hey, you've got dice, right?
Tim Ferriss: Cool. Yeah.
Elan Lee: They're everything. They're absolutely
everything. So the first thing I would look for
is what can I do with these very simple components
that creates a core gameplay loop that I'm excited
about? And I can rattle off 12 of those in an
hour. That's honestly not the hard part.
Tim Ferriss: 12 different gameplay
loops that you're familiar with?
Elan Lee: That I'm excited about,
that I can just invent it. They're not that
hard. It's like, okay, look, I'm going to give
you a card and I'm going to keep a card and
whoever has the highest card wins, but first
we're going to have a conversation and, I'm making
this up as I go, I'm going to try to bluff you,
I'm going to try to get you to discard your card
because you don't think there's any chance you
can win and you can still earn a little bit if
I can get you to fold with — right? Those are
easy. I can come up with a ton of those, right?
And again, you notice the crux of that was,
we're entertaining each other. The conversation is
actually the game, the cards don't matter. That's
just my mantra over and over and over again.
So we do that, come up with a bunch of those, and
then I need another person. I need at least one
person that I can show these to, play the games
with, and I only care about one question. In fact,
we do all these play tests, we don't even give
out surveys anymore. There's only one question we
ask, which is, "When you finish playing the game,
did you want to play again?" And a game is
done when 100 percent of the people say yes.
And it never starts that way, it's always a whole
bunch of nos, and let me tell you why and all that
stuff, but that's the only question I care about.
When you finished, did you want to play again?
And if I can get a little bit of
positive feedback there from a person
showing a bunch of concepts too, and one of
them, they say, "Ooh, let's play that one again,"
then you've got to start thinking about, okay, why
did they want to play that again? Well, maybe they
had so much fun, they wanted to play again. Maybe
they thought they could do better the second time,
kind of a sense of mastery that maybe they could
achieve by playing again. And I try to identify
what that thing is, what that compelling, that
thing that kept pulling them back in and double
down on that, right? That's the thing I want to
shine most in the game, I'll start building the
surrounding components all to emphasize that thing
over and over and over again. And then generously,
you let me have play testers at the end, I'll
start showing it to them, right? That is the
point where I've got, my components are done,
my core gameplay loop is done, I've got a few
of the peripheral things that are starting to
get those cylinders to fire. Now let me put it
through the paces and see what people think.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so let's say day one,
so day one, you get seated in your
comfortable yet not-too-comfortable cell,
you have this hamster bottle full of coffee.
Elan Lee: Yeah, yeah. Good, good. I love it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. You've got unlimited
ramen and you have a table, you've got
your blank cards, paper, sharpies. What is your
brainstorming, if that's the right word to use,
look like? Right? Is it questions? Is it
drawing cards? Visually or otherwise, it's
just you sitting there staring at the wall, kind
of running through things, rehearsing different
things in your mind, what would that look like?
Elan Lee: I think the way that I approach that
is I always imagine two of me, and when I have
— I need to physically touch and hold things,
right? So even if the cards are blank, I do need
to hold six cards and shuffle six cards. And so
if I'm holding them and I think, okay, me standing
in front of me, if I were to give you this thing,
what conversation could we have? I think it's
a lot like script writing. I start with the
conflict. What is it that's going to drive the
conversation? We can't be getting along, we can't
have the same motivation. Me handing this thing to
you better create a conflict that now we're going
to try to resolve. And that's really it. I think
that's where all good ideas start from is here we
are in a room, there can be only one, so how are
we going to resolve that? Because here we are,
staring at a bunch of blank cards.
Tim Ferriss: Looking at the company,
it strikes me that you have chosen lanes very
well to plan. And what I mean by that is,
you have not, as far as I can tell, maybe
you have, so correct me if I'm wrong, but you
haven't gone off into the incredibly complex, $200
game that requires three hours to get the basics
down, after which it requires probably 20 hours
of play to get to sort of intermediate level.
There are a lot of those games, and a lot of the
hobby shops seem to favor those games for a lot
of reasons that I think are understandable.
I mean, the diehards love diehard products.
What other guiding principles do you have?
For instance, two-player versus you need
three or four players to get started. Any
other elements that are integral pieces of
the DNA of your design process?
Elan Lee: This is stuff I just
don't think often about. It just sort of
happens. So this is awesome. All right.
When I was growing up, the biggest frustration
I had with games was, first and foremost,
the instructions. I don't have the patience to
even read 20 minutes, let alone the seven hours to
get into those crazy games. And so I really wanted
to make games that 10-year-old me would really get
a kick out of. And if you read, one of the things
I'm most proud of about our instructions is any
of the instructions you look at, the very first
thing your eyes are going to be drawn to is this
box that says, "Hey, don't read these rules.
Reading is the worst way to learn how to play
a game. Instead, go to our website and we'll just
walk you through it in four minutes." And we made
a video. We have a how to play video.
Tim Ferriss: In video.
Elan Lee: Yeah, right. And we did that for
every game, and I insisted on it. And it's
expensive, but I insist on that. Absolutely
insist to every game, don't read the instructions,
even though we spent months working on the
instructions. So that's one hugely important
thing to me. You should be able to pick up
the game in five minutes and you shouldn't
even have to read to do it. You should
just sit down, watch a thing, you're done.
Second thing is, of course, like I was talking
about, the game just has to be a tool set for
the other players to be entertaining. I think
the other ones though are a game cannot feel
fragile. And I don't mean the physical
components, I mean, it can't be too easy to cheat.
You shouldn't ever feel motivated to outsmart
the game. The game needs to just say, look,
you already know you've already got everything
you need to play. We're just going to tweak
the world a little bit. What if you could
only speak using single-syllable words?
We're not getting involved too much. This thing
will always stand out no matter what you throw
at it. That's really important as well, because
so many games, I have a bookshelf with literally
hundreds of games and so many of them, I
realized I accidentally broke the rules.
The game was just too fragile. I didn't mean to,
it just keeps happening. And then I think also,
a game should be beautiful. You should look at
a game and smile. It should be a source of joy.
These things should be dopamine engines, and part
of that is you want to hold the thing and show it
to all your friends. And that's actually probably
the actual final one, which is when you are done
playing, your first instinct, well, after "I want
to play again," your second instinct, I'll say,
is, "I'm going to put this in my bag and take
it to my buddy's house because I am going to
get a little bit of more joy
by sharing this with someone."
And the thing starts to have a life.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I'll give you just
an anecdote on Poetry for Neanderthals. My
recommendation for folks, if you play this,
first of all, your mileage may vary, right?
I don't believe that the whole world is just
comprised of different-sized Tims. That's not the
case. However, my recommendation is, don't do what
I and my friends did, which is we decided we were
going to play with three people to 100 points,
we had to win by a certain margin of points, and
that's not doing any exercise for six months and
deciding you're going to do the leg workout from
Arnold Schwarzenegger from 1974. We all felt it
the next day. We're like, wow, some portion
of our brain has not been used in that way.
Elan Lee: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: We really put
it under extreme duress. But I do recommend
people check it out. I want to flash back to
your mention of the hundreds of games that
you have. As someone who was a super devoted
D&D player for a long time, which may
seem, I'll just explain to folks, may seem
to contradict something that I named
as the appeal of a lot of your games,
which is the simplicity. D&D, especially when I
was playing — and I have First Edition Player's
Handbook and Dungeon Master's Guide and so on,
I still have all of my modules and campaigns
and everything, is extremely in-depth. But it is
also one of the best games I've ever found for
co-creating a narrative and finding
one another and making one another
interesting and entertaining. It
is just one of the great wonders
of the world as far as I'm concerned.
Elan Lee: Would you say it enhanced your
friendships with the players?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, 100 percent.
Elan Lee: Right.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, there were these occasional
flareups, as you might imagine, especially if a
dungeon master was in a pissy mood and decided to
really damage someone who was getting on his
nerves, but it was the defining, let's just
call it, sport of that section of my childhood.
Because I was a runt, I got the shit kicked out
of me constantly at school. There were a handful
of other kids who fit the same description and we
banded together, I guess much like Stranger
Things but minus the aliens and everything,
to play D&D. That was where we could shine.
But the reason I bring it up is that I have
played relatively few games. I've played
a lot of the classics. I've played Chess,
I've played Backgammon, I've played Japanese
Chess, I've played Go, et cetera, but now sort
of sidestepping my way nervously into the gaming
world, tabletop games have exploded. There are
a million different genres and what I've heard
in some interviews, not with you, but of game
designers, is you have to keep up with the times.
You've got to watch where the ball is going. It
seems like an arms race on some level, and I'm
skeptical of it. I'm skeptical of that because
it seems like you could end up chasing fads and
you decide, "Oh, Pokémon GO is really big. People
are running through Central Park tripping
over benches." And if you do it incorrectly,
you basically just fizzle because that was a
flash in the pan, not to say that that's true.
I'm wondering about the hundreds of games that you
have. If you were to teach a three-hour class on
the periodic table of elements for games and
you're like, "These are some of the canonical
games or types of games that you must be familiar
with, just like a chef has to know salt, oil,
sweet, sour, umami," some of these basics,
what would some of the candidates be for that?
Elan Lee: Oh, okay. Oh, yeah. Okay. Stretching
here because this is going to be — okay.
First of all, let me say, I will admit
I am a fish out of water here. I've never played
D&D literally ever. I've never played any of those
crazy 10-hour strategy games. I'm missing out
on that experience. I would love to have that
experience. Lately I've been pretty busy, so it
just hasn't come up. I don't even know how to talk
about this, but I will say that I have played
a ton of board games and a ton of card games,
and there is — you're right. There's a language,
there's a core ingredient list that's important.
All right. The first one that's become really
popular right now — I'm sure there's like a
fancy industry term for it, but it's kind of like
a fill-in-the-blank game: Cards Against Humanity,
What Do You Meme, Joking Hazard, Apples to Apples,
and the basic structure is always the same.
There's a writer's room somewhere, they told
a whole bunch of funny jokes, they cut them
up into pieces, and now you are going to get
credit for reassembling those jokes. That's
the basic principle, right? So, you have
a card, it's your turn, you play a card,
everyone's got a hand of cards, you play your
card — I'm going to not to quote another game,
so I'm going to just make up a completely
false game, which is, "What is the
best thing I could wear on my head?" It's a
dumb example, but it illustrates the point.
Everyone else has a bunch of cards. I've got a
banana, a beach ball, turbine, et cetera. We're
all going to play a card. Whoever's turn it was
is going to vote on which one they thought was
the best, that person gets a point, off we go.
There's a bunch of games like that. They're very
popular right now. It's an important kind of
genre because it's really funny. The best ones
make you laugh so hard you can barely
breathe. They're just incredible.
The next one — let's see. Where should
we go next? Okay, the next one, I think,
is called — I'm going to call it deck building.
And the idea is there's a whole bunch of cards,
each card does something very, very special
and powerful, but they're all community cards
at first. You play the game by trying to remove
things from the community into your own private
stash so that then you can deploy them and beat
the other players. Every card has a power and a
weakness. You're trying to collect the best ones
you can in order to obliterate everybody else.
That's also a very popular, pretty standard one.
Tim Ferriss: If someone wanted to do a sort of
a chef's menu tasting of these different games,
is there one that comes to mind that fits that?
Elan Lee: Yeah. For that one, there's a
game out there called Dominion, which is —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, very popular.
Elan Lee: Yeah, that's a good one
to start with for deck building. Okay. Next
is, of course, collectible trading card games:
Pokémon, Magic: The Gathering, things like that.
I won't go into too much detail on that because,
again, I must admit, I have never played any of
those. I just don't know anything about them.
Tim Ferriss: Justin Gary, who came up earlier,
is a good person to look into it. I think he was
the youngest ever national champion in Magic: The
Gathering. Really knows that genre inside and out
so people can check him out.
Elan Lee: Yeah, perfect.
There's physical dexterity games, physical or
dexterity games. The idea is to play this game,
you have to do something physical and whoever does
either the physical thing the best or makes it so
they can impede other people's physical progress
will win at those kinds of games. We have one
out there, it's one of my favorite games ever.
It's called Throw Throw Burrito. It's dodgeball
and card games all mixed into one. You try to
collect cards while simultaneously throwing soft,
squishy burritos at the other players. Collect
a card, gain a point, get hit with a burrito,
lose a point. Trying to do both those things
at once is where the chaos comes from.
Let's see. I'm sure there's like
a ton more that I'm missing.
I'm kind of glancing over games here trying to —
Tim Ferriss: If there are any games where,
even if you can't name the
genre, you're like, "Really,
you must play this," in the same way that
if someone came up to me and they said,
"I want to be a long-form non-fiction book
writer." Not that I would be the most qualified
teacher of all time, but I would definitely
have certain books in mind where I would say,
"Okay, here are five or six you've got to read."
Elan Lee: There's a few games I've encountered
in my life that have felt so natural that it
doesn't feel like anybody invented them. It's like
two plus two equals four, like nobody invented
that. They just realized the way to phrase it.
There's a game out there called SET that I
believe falls perfectly into that category.
I'm not even going to describe what it is,
because you should just go and try this game.
Tim Ferriss: It's a cool game.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I've played
SET. It is a very cool game.
Elan Lee: It's one of those games that I used
to play this with my sister, who's 16 years
younger than me. When she was 10 and I was 26,
she would regularly kick my ass at that game,
and it's because it activates this part of
your brain that either exists or doesn't.
I'm sure a lot of people are just horrible
at it, but it is so neat to see a master
hit that flow state with this game. They're
discovering patterns that are right there in front
of everybody else, it's just they can see them and
you can't. It's beautiful. It's just beautiful.
Tim Ferriss: Side note. This is not going
to mean anything to most people, but
in my limited anecdotal experience, I would love
to know if I were able to have a few drinks with
the creators of this game, if they find women to
get into those flow states more easily, because
I have, at least in my experience, seen that.
It raises all sorts of cool questions, I think.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Yeah. I wonder how you describe
that skillset. What are the words to describe that
skill? I have no idea, but it's so beautiful to
watch a master. It gives me chills. Let's see. The
last one I'll say is — I'm trying to find the
right category for something like Monopoly,
because there's a whole genre of game where it's
like resource management, resource collection.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Trading like
Settlers of Catan and so on.
Elan Lee: Let's talk about Settlers of Catan
for a second, because for me there is a really
interesting category there. That is one of the
few hardcore games I've played. I know a lot of
people would call it not hardcore, but whatever. I
once challenged a group of designers. I was like,
"Describe to me the core gameplay loop of Settlers
of Catan." By the way, I don't know the proper way
to pronounce that word. Catan, Catan.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, me neither.
Elan Lee: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Tomato. Tomato.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Right, right, right. "Describe
to me the core gameplay of Catan," and all three
of them said the same thing or variations, which
was, "That's a game about collecting resources,
spending those resources to expand the fastest."
And I thought, that's not what that game is.
That's not how I play that game. That game is
a social game. That game is a trading game. I
don't even care about the game. All I care
about is my interactions and relationships
with the other players, because that's how you win
or lose. It was so fascinating to see that these
are really experienced game designers. We were
playing a different game, completely different,
even though we both read the same rules.
Tim Ferriss: Question: were they experienced
gamers — maybe people don't like that
term or they automatically think digital,
but were they experienced game players but not
extremely experienced Catan or Catan players?
Because my friends who love — I'm just going to
say "Catan" because I'm American and like hard
"A"s — they do think of it as a trading game.
There's a lot of game theory. For instance,
there's some people who won't make a trade unless
it clearly benefits them. But I have a friend
who's very successful, and if something doesn't
clearly significantly hamper him in the early
stages, he will make a trade because of the social
capital that he builds up the set of credit for
later, asking for a trade. He's very successful.
Elan Lee: That's fair. You're right. I don't know
that they were successful or experienced Catan
players, but that's great. That's really astute.
I hadn't thought about it in that context. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: We may come back to the periodic
table of elements and this is — I'm becoming
immersed in this world, number one, because
I want to spend more time off of screens. I want
also help other people do that, and the way I'm
hoping to do that is by designing a game of some
type or collaborating with people to build a game.
Elan Lee: Good.
Tim Ferriss: I just
think that's the only way for me to really
even make an attempt at trying to understand
it is to roll up my sleeves. You invoked a name
earlier that I want to revisit: Jordan Weisman.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And you
called him your mentor. Who is Jordan and
what are some of the lessons you've learned or
things that you have modeled from your mentor?
Elan Lee: I met Jordan Weisman at Microsoft.
Jordan Weisman is one of the most famous game
designers ever. He designed BattleTech. He
designed Crimson Skies. The list goes on and
on, but I met him — you know when you go to
a virtual reality center and you play any of
these immersive games, where you're sitting in
a big robot fighting against other robots? He
designed all of that and invented all of that,
and actually opened the first virtual reality
spaces ever in history. I met him at Microsoft.
At the time, I was hired right out of college onto
this Xbox group and they hired me as a producer.
I don't know anything about producing,
but they hired me. I thought, "Oh,
cool. I think I work in the video game industry."
Tim Ferriss: What does that even mean? Because in
Hollywood, producer can be a million things.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Fair enough.
Tim Ferriss: What does it mean in this context?
Elan Lee: The person in charge of a project.
They actually call it the program manager there.
It's the person who's responsible for schedule and
budget and staffing for a project.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Yeah.
Elan Lee: They hired me right out of college
into this role and the creative director
for the whole studio was this guy, Jordan.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sorry to keep interrupting. Why
would they hire you right out of college?
Elan Lee: Because I was a terrible, terrible,
terrible student. I failed out of many colleges,
but I had some really good internships. The star
internship I got just talking my way in the
front door was at Industrial Light & Magic.
Tim Ferriss: Ah, you son of a bitch.
Elan Lee: Yeah, right? I got to work
on Star Wars and I got to put that on
my resume. When I applied at Microsoft,
I basically said, "Ignore my transcripts.
Ignore my history. Star Wars. Star Wars. Star
Wars." And they said, "Sure. Yeah, come on over."
Tim Ferriss: Is it true that you are responsible
for the beautiful neck of Jar Jar Binks?
Elan Lee: I like that you put in the right
qualifier there: the neck. Yes. I did not work
on Jar Jar Binks; I worked on the connective
tissue on his neck that tied the CG face
to the physical actor's body so that it
didn't tear as he moved around. That was my job.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. You don't want any injuries in
the Star Wars universe, unless they're very
interesting. All right. So, you get hired,
but you've done this internship, that shines
through, you get hired to be the producer?
Elan Lee: Yeah. They put me on the Xbox.
They basically said, "We need six games.
Here's $200 million. Don't fuck up." That was it.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sorry to belabor this.
Hold on. This is one thing — okay. $200 million
is a lot of money. What gave them confidence that
you could go from the neck of Jar Jar Binks to
managing $200 million? I mean, were there other
safeguards in place? That's a lot of money.
Elan Lee: They didn't give me $200 million.
They gave Jordan $200 million. I just —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, okay. Okay, okay, okay.
Elan Lee: All right. So Jordan hired me. I
must have been working there for two weeks,
where he pulled me aside and he said, "You're
a terrible producer. You're just awful."
And I said, "Yeah, I know." But to his credit,
I don't know why. He said, "I think you might
be a really good designer, so we're going to
switch roles." I don't quite know what it is
he saw in me, but he said, "I'm going to help
train you and you're going to help design games
instead of produce them. We have very talented
people for that, far better than you. Let's try
this." He immediately just started throwing me on
projects, with projects like Halo and saying like,
"Go do this. Go help with this thing." It was
great. Obviously, the first six games for the
Xbox that came out were great. They set the tone
for what the Xbox was and I got a ton of credit,
again, all because of Jordan, because
he saw something in me and said,
"Go play in this arena instead."
I think maybe the best way to
describe who Jordan is — years later,
we'd started a few companies together
right at the point — when was this? This was
when George W. Bush had just won his second term.
All my friends were upset. Everyone kept, "Oh,
God. The system is rigged. It's not fair. He
shouldn't have won again. He was so bad the
first." All this stuff. I don't care what your
political persuasions are, but a whole bunch of
people were just complaining. I would always ask
the same question, "Well, did you vote?" And they
would all say, "Well, no, it doesn't matter." I
got so upset. I was like, "Oh, there's just this
one tool you have and you're not using your one
tool." I sat down with Jordan and he said, "This
reminds me a lot..." I was complaining about this
thing. "All my friends, they're not voting and
they still have the audacity to complain about
it." And he said, "Okay, this reminds me a lot
of the story of how the US was founded. There was
a bunch of upset people and they eventually did
something about it." And he said, "You know what
we should do?" Because it's Jordan, he said,
"We should start a clothing company." Right?
I was like, "Well, I'm not following this at
all, but, yes. You know what? Let's go. Let's
do it." What we did was we started this clothing
company, where we made these beautiful shirts.
It was mostly a t-shirt company. We put out a
whole line of t-shirts. Each one was gorgeous,
beautiful. We hired the best artists in the
world and just designed these shirts. But
every shirt had hidden, inside of it, a secret
code or hidden message somewhere in the shirt.
Sometimes it was right on the printing, like you
had to fold your shirt a certain way and get the
graphics to line up and you could read —
suddenly, a secret message would appear.
But we used things like invisible inks, we use
things like glow-in-the dark inks, thermal inks,
like get your shirt hot and suddenly a message
would appear. If you could figure out the message,
you'd take it to the website, you enter in the
message, and a little movie would start playing,
a little two-minute clip. It was basically a TV
show. Every shirt had its own two-minute clip.
They fit together like a TV show. It was episodic
and each one would end in a cliffhanger. "If you
want to know what happens next, awesome, go
buy another shirt." That was our business.
Tim Ferriss: How did he go from the prompt
of you being upset about voting to make
the conceptual leapfrog move to that?
Elan Lee: Because Jordan's like the
most brilliant guy in the world. The episodic
story that we were telling was about a band.
And the band had a very oppressive producer
that was stealing all their money, was just
making a huge mess for them. It got so bad that
eventually a member of the band got murdered and —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that is bad.
Elan Lee: Really bad, right? Who did it?
That was the crux of the story. What we never told
players of this game, this clothing-based game,
because this was Jordan's actual brilliant
idea, was as you progressed through this,
the players figured out that this is a
beat for beat retelling of the founding
of the United States. Every character has a
historic counterpart. The bass player, Adam,
was John Adams. The leader of the band, Jeff,
was Thomas Jefferson. And by listening to the
story and piecing it all together, you're actually
learning the story of the founding of the country
and why they did it and what they were rebelling
against and why they were so unhappy and why they
created a way for them to work their way through
this system. I'm so proud to say — our players,
millions of them, they started canvassing
their neighborhoods, showing up to Rock the
Vote parties, and they got — I don't remember
the exact number, so bear with me, but it was
hundreds of thousands of new registered
voters through this clothing company.
That's really the beauty of Jordan is I can go
to him with a statement like, "None of my friends
voted," he can say, "Let's start a clothing
company," and the answer is a hundred thousand
more people voted next time. It's so cool.
Tim Ferriss: That's amazing.
Elan Lee: It's so cool.
Tim Ferriss: Jordan may have
some unusual hardwiring that enables him to do
certain things, just like Michael Jordan may
have some unusual hardwiring that allows him to
jump and do certain things physically. However,
there are probably certain principles, certain
commandments that you could distill if you had
to. If Jordan said, "Look, you can have 10 hours
of conversation with me and then you have to teach
the 10 Commandments of Jordan Weisman to this
freshman class..." Or it could be junior class,
whatever. Just let's assume they're serious. I'm
not going to ask you to name 10, but do any come
to mind whether sort of quintessential Jordan?
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: They don't have to be commandments.
They could be anything that comes to mind.
Elan Lee: Yeah. There's a few that are immediate,
because he just drilled them into my head.
One is "Nothing attracts a crowd like a crowd."
Try as hard as you want to market something,
get a crowd. That's what actually matters.
Another one that he still says all the time is,
"You've got a violin, I've got
a barn. Let's put on a show.
Don't overthink this, just go. Tomorrow,
put on a show. You'll learn a lot and
that's fine. You'll fail and that's fine,
too. Just go." Yeah, that one was — man,
took me forever to figure out, but so important.
Tim Ferriss: Now, does that apply in the context
of how you knew Jordan in the sense — and I've
heard other people say this. "You can think about
it for five hours or you can test it for five
minutes and you're going to get the same benefit."
Elan Lee: Yeah, that's right. Exactly.
Yeah. He really burned that into me.
I started the alternate reality company with
Jordan. If I were in charge of that company,
we would have been paralyzed. I would've been too
scared to do anything. But Jordan called up Steven
Spielberg and said, "We've got this company. We
can market your game better than anybody else
in the world. You should hire us." And they
did. We had no product, we had no idea what
the hell we were doing, and suddenly with Steven
Spielberg, we built the world's first alternate
reality game because Jordan made a phone call.
Tim Ferriss: Hold on. Was he like croquet
partners with the Spielberg family, went to
the same social club? How does that happen?
Elan Lee: All right. It was a little different.
I was at Microsoft — all right, so here's how
this story actually rolled out. I was working at
Microsoft doing this new designer, no idea what
the hell I'm doing, and one day Steven Spielberg
walks into my office. Seriously, right? He sits
down and he says, "I've got to talk to you." He
says, "Your boss, Jordan, just paid Warner Bros.,
I don't know, $600 million, whatever it
is, for the rights to my new movie, AI.
Apparently your job is you've got to make four
video games about this movie. So I thought I
should sit down and chat with you about what
this movie is so we could get started." That's
how I met Spielberg. Jordan just sent him to my
office and said, "Go talk to that guy." Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Not the worst day. Not the worst day.
Elan Lee: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Man, that was a weird
place. It was so inspiring, so much fun, but
stuff like that would literally happen every day.
The way that actually rolled out, unfortunately,
we built four games. We built an adventure game,
we built a racing game, we built a
gladiatorial combat game. Jordan said,
"Look, the thing we really have to do is we need
glue between these things. We need a way to take
players from one game to the other game to the
other game. We've got this incredible narrative,
but how do you understand how they all
fit together? We need the glue." So,
we hired this incredible writer, a guy named
Sean Stewart, to write a story about the glue.
He wrote it. It was a tearjerker, just this
incredible, incredible narrative. Then the
movie was done, we finished all the games, we went
to the premiere. I don't know if you remember this
movie, but the movie is about an android boy who
is adopted by a human family, who eventually — all
this android boy wants is to be loved. He wants
his mother's affection, and eventually he is
denied that. He is abandoned in the forest, no
one loves him, he's left to fend for himself,
he witnesses everybody die. He, in fact, witnesses
all of humanity go extinct and never actually
achieves love. I don't know about you, but I don't
think anybody's walking out of that movie thinking
like, "I can't wait to play the Xbox game," right?
Tim Ferriss:
Those people who came out and
they're like, "I'm really depressed,
but I'm not yet ready to kill myself. How
can I push this just a little further?"
Elan Lee: Yeah. So, we went back to work
and we thought, "Oh, it's heartbreaking,
but we've got to cancel all of these
games. We just can't make any of them."
So we canceled them, but we thought like —
Tim Ferriss: No, wait. Hold on a second. Now,
presumably when you sat down and Spielberg's
like, "Okay, kid, let me tell you what this
movie's about," you had some insight into the
storyline and the arc of this movie. So did it
come as a surprise or were you just like, "Maybe
they'll change it. Maybe the studio will be like,
'Steven. Please, Steve, baby, we've
got to change the ending.'" To what
extent was it a surprise or were you're
like, "Hey, we're getting paid well,
let's do our best, and then..."
Elan Lee: It was a surprise, but it
was intentional. This was a collaboration between
Spielberg and Kubrick. Spielberg adopted a Kubrick
script and he really didn't want a lot of people
to know what it was going to be about or the final
implementation. We did have the script, but it was
a version like 10 versions back, so it was very,
very different. But by design, that was part
of their kind of surprise marketing was like,
"Nobody actually knows what this
is until we're ready to show you."
Unfortunately, we were some of those people.
Tim Ferriss: Makes it rougher
for the game designers.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Oh, man.
So we have to cancel all the games. We'd
spent a year building these things. I was
sitting down with Jordan basically crying, just
like, "This is the worst. Everything we worked on
is getting canceled now." But we thought, "You
know what? Remember that glue? That was pretty
cool. That narrative was really, really good."
Tim Ferriss: And by glue, you mean sort of the
narrative connective tissue
that was woven by Sean?
Elan Lee: By Sean Stewart, yeah. Yeah. It
was, again, this just beautiful story. It
didn't have any engine associated with it.
It was just a few hundred script pages of the
story of characters that lived in the same
world as AI and went through it with them,
landing from set piece to set piece to set piece,
which at the time were the Xbox games. We thought
even if you remove the Xbox Games, this is still
a beautiful story. I wonder if there was a way
to put it out into the world. I remember I was
sitting, again, heartbroken with Jordan. We were
at a sushi restaurant and in Seattle, and I was
saying, "Ah, there's got to be a way we can put
out at least that story, at least that," and
his phone rang. He looked at me and he said,
"What if that was the story calling us right
now?" My brain just exploded. I was just like,
"I have no idea what that means, but it feels
really significant." Then we sat down and
we started building what is now known as the
first alternate reality game for Warner Bros.,
for Spielberg, because we still had this
contract, we canceled all the games that we
had to deliver something for marketing their
game, their movie, excuse me. So we decided,
"All right, what if we take this beautiful story,
cut it up into a million pieces, hide it all over
the planet, and let players reassemble it, and the
finale of our story is the launch of the movie?"
Which turned out to be called The Beast.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. What a great story.
Elan Lee: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you for sharing.
Elan Lee: That was so fun. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You have such a broad
spectrum of experience with games and interactions
of all different types, a human with component,
player with player. There's such a multifactorial
set of experience that you have. Right now,
you have this company, you have
many games. If you were able to
operate under a pen name and make a game that it
doesn't have to do at all with Exploding Kittens,
is there some game that you're like, "God,
if there were a way, if I just had the time,
if I could have my druthers, a type of game or
anything?" Maybe you don't want to share it or who
knows? But is there something you're like, "God, I
wish this existed in the world and I would make it
if I were just in a slightly different spot?"
Elan Lee: All right. I'm going to tell you
something I'm not allowed to tell
you, but I'm going to tell you anyway
'cause, man, you set me right up for this
one, so here you go. I have two kids. I have
a five-year-old and a one-year-old. Last year,
my five-year-old was four. Of course, I tried
playing games with her, I hate playing games with
her, hate it. It's because the games you can buy
for kids are awful. They're the worst games. "If
I have to play Candy Land one more fucking time…"
So I dread it, and she's having a blast.
She's getting attention, so she loves it.
She's like, "Daddy, can we play again?" I'm just
like, "Oh, please, no, anything, anything but play
again." I started thinking, "This feels really
broken." You know when someone like Eddie Murphy
disappears for a while, and then he does a bunch
of kids' films and everyone's scratching their
head and they're like, "Why are you doing a bunch
of kids' films?" That's not what we know him for.
All right. I'm about to tell you that story. I
started thinking about, why are kids games so
awful? What I realized is the model is wrong.
What if the model instead was Pixar, where —
Tim Ferriss: I was just going to —
Elan Lee: Yeah —
Tim Ferriss: I knew you were going to go to Pixar.
Elan Lee: Right. Right.
Tim Ferriss: Ah, so good. So good.
Elan Lee: Right. Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: So what if the kids could
have an experience that they love and the parents
could have a different experience through the same
tool set that they love as well?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: For the last two years, every night with
my daughter, we get out the paper and the stickers
and the markers, and we just make games every
night. Every night. We made, I don't know, 20,
30 of these things, but a few of them are really
good, really good. She helped me design them,
and we worked. We play them all the time, and
now she's sharing them with her friends, and —
Tim Ferriss: I don't want to insult your
daughter's intelligence, but she's five
currently, right?
Elan Lee: Yes. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: It's quality time, so it's not
like you're like, "Come on, pull it together.
You need to earn your keep around here.
What does this look like, a nonprofit?" But
how do you interact? I think this
would be helpful for parents —
Elan Lee: Of course.
Tim Ferriss: — even if they
don't care about game design.
Elan Lee: So my daughter is still
in that phase where everything is about her.
She has no awareness if I'm having fun or not,
everything's about her.
Tim Ferriss: I think
there are a lot of adults who are still there.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Yeah. Fair enough. Yeah, I could
tell you stories there too. The interactions with
her, the game design is like, "How do I make sure
that she's being celebrated, that she is winning
a game?" But for me, what's going on in the
background is, "I cannot let her win. I have to be
trying my hardest and she has to beat me anyway."
Tim Ferriss: Okay. That sounds hard.
Elan Lee: It's so hard, it's so hard.
Tim Ferriss: Like severe, severe handicapping.
Elan Lee: Yeah. It's really hard and we went
through a ton of games where that wasn't the
case, where I found, "Oh, I'm letting her win
again. Let's scrap this thing and try something
else." we eventually ended up with a handful of
games that all satisfy that criteria that
I don't let her win, and she wins anyway,
that I'm having a blast, she's having a blast.
The best thing is, at the end of it, she says,
"Can we play again?" I'm like, "Hell, yes.
I'm so glad you asked. Yes, let's play again."
the part I'm not allowed to tell you, but
I'm going to tell you anyway is this little
five-year-old is going to have a handful of games
in retail this coming year that she helped design.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's so cool.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That's so cool.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, man. Getting the dad gold star.
Elan Lee: It's so much fun.
Tim Ferriss: When she's a teenager and she's
like, "I hate you, Dad," and you'll be like,
"Never forget what I did for you."
Elan Lee: She's got such a skewed
perspective. Imagine if she thinks this is just
normal, "This is what all families do. You make
games and you put them in a store." That's what —
Tim Ferriss: I'm just imagining she's
at the bouncy castle at her
friend's sixth birthday party,
"Oh, yeah. What are you up to?
Are you having fun?" "Yeah,
I decorated a cake." She's like, "Oh, that's
cute. Yeah, I have three games at Walmart."
So speaking of sales, it's going to
be an abrupt, awkward transition —
Elan Lee: Okay. Okay.
Tim Ferriss: — but I bookmarked something
you said earlier that I didn't want to interrupt
with at the time, but when you were talking about
the first three to four years of games coming
out of Exploding Kittens, direct-to-consumer
and then adding to Amazon, and you had a line that
was something along the lines of, "Amazon quickly
eclipsed our ability to sell our own games."
Is that because when people would search for,
I'm just making this up, "Exploding Kittens,"
the SEO was such that people would be taken
to Kickstarter? Most people are unfamiliar with
Kickstarter, therefore the conversions would be
very low. But once it's on Amazon, which
also functions as its own search engine,
but happens to have very good discoverability on
something like Google, did that increase sales,
or is there something more to it?
Elan Lee: Everything you said is
true with one extra point, which is,
when a Kickstarter campaign closes,
the Back This Project button
changes to a link to a website.
So now there's an extra barrier to entry. You go
to the Kickstarter page, you click this thing,
it takes you through to another page. From there,
you've got to navigate to where the purchase
button is. That was too much for people. Amazon
is just, "Here's the buy button right here."
Tim Ferriss: Do you have any idea, this
is going back to the archives, I know,
but it just occurred to me that probably their
recommendation engine could not have hurt you,
"If you like this game, you may also
like Exploding Kittens," but I don't
know if that was a rounding error or if
it ended up adding up to significant,
additive sales. Do you have any idea?
Elan Lee: I actually don't know for sure.
What I know about Amazon is when we launched,
there were so many stories that had come out
about the phenomenal success on Kickstarter that
what worked to our advantage was, here's this
incredible thing, "More people backed this than
any other project ever, and it made all this money
and you can't have it." That was the story, 'cause
there was literally no way to get it. You missed
the 30-day window. So when we finally said, "Hey,
it's available on Amazon," we had something like
20,000 orders in the first hour.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Elan Lee: It was just nuts because
suddenly it was, "All right. Well…"
Tim Ferriss: Nothing attracts
a crowd like a crowd, right?
Elan Lee: There you go. That's exactly right.
Tim Ferriss: Because the launch itself became
a story that helped to —
Elan Lee: Huge event, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — further perpetuate the sales.
Elan Lee: Right. So now, we've got 20,000
orders in an hour. Now we're at the top of all
the search results on Amazon. You search for the
word "Game," and it's all Exploding Kittens,
because the algorithm feeds on itself. So
I cannot claim any credit for that. That worked
in our favor perfectly. All we did was just take
full advantage of it and just kept leveraging it.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. "Exploding Kittens, Lightning
in a bottle. Holy shit. Now what?" Right?
Elan Lee: Now what?
Tim Ferriss: That when you build this company,
which we could spend dozens of hours just
discussing the company-building process —
Elan Lee: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — one of my questions for you,
because again, this is serving my interest,
'cause I'm curious in all of this, but you don't
necessarily have to name Voldemort and the things
that you don't like, although I'm curious, maybe
another time over a glass of wine or something.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: With the
success of Exploding Kittens, no doubt, you
had a lot of inbound from people who want to
option it or adapt it for different uses in all
sorts of different media and formats and so on.
As a company, probably at some point
there was at least a discussion of,
"How can we expand this franchise without
damaging and maybe even strengthening our core
business?" What might that look like?
What paths of exploration have been
most fruitful or enjoyable?
Elan Lee: Oh, I like this one.
Okay. So we deployed the same principle after
Kickstarter as during Kickstarter, which was,
'We've got to stay focused." For the first little
while, all it was, was "We must fulfill every
single order." We made a whole bunch of promises.
We thought we were shipping out a few thousand
games. We have to ship out 700,000 games our very
first order. That was literally our first purchase
order. It was like, "Okay. Well, that's really
hard." So we've got to first figure out logistics.
We've got to figure out warehousing. We've got
to figure out everything, everything, 'cause we —
Tim Ferriss: Customer service.
Elan Lee: Right. I
Tim Ferriss: Tracking.
Elan Lee: Seriously, I thought,
"We're going to fulfill this out of my garage.
I'm going to invite a few friends over. I'll
order some pizza and beers and we're done." An
average game will sell maybe 50,000 units a year,
and we're doing 700,000 in 30 days. It's just
nuts, absolutely nuts. So the first thing was,
"Stay focused." I'm so happy to say we delivered
every single one of those items on time,
with the exception of the orders to Russia, which
is a whole 'nother story that makes me very upset,
but we got them out there.
All right. I have to tell you
the Russia story, 'cause holy crap. All right.
So we didn't have many, we had 16, maybe 20
orders in Russia, and we shipped them all out.
Then we started getting these emails from our
Russian backers saying, "I never got my game."
We're like, "Wait, you definitely got your
game. We've got the confirmation right here."
They said, "Nope, never got it." All of them,
"Nope, never got it." So I call up the customs,
there's a special name for it, customs in Russia,
essentially. All of them go through this one
warehouse. I said, "Hey, I'm trying to track
down these 16 orders, what's going on?" They said,
"Oh, yeah. Those were never delivered." I said,
"Well, I've got the confirmation right here that
they were delivered." They said, "Oh, it's illegal
to import games into Russia, so our policy is to
destroy them and then mark them as delivered."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Illegal to import games.
Elan Lee: Yeah. I never figured
that one out. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: There must have
been some very interesting political
contest going on. Can you imagine?
Elan Lee: I can't even begin to wrap my
head around that one. Of all the things
to consider a threat like this silly
little kitten-based card game. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I will say, though,
I have heard many stories,
in many cases, first-time game designers getting
themselves into financial difficulties because
especially if they have a predominant overseas
backer base, when games are inspected, damaged,
having holes punched through them.
Elan Lee: Right.
Tim Ferriss: You can get yourself into an
accounts receivable, accounts payable problem.
Elan Lee: It's nuts. It's such a huge problem.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: Oh, man, shipping and insurance on that
shipping is so expensive and everyone expects it
to be free or nearly free. When we show people the
bill, we're like, "Look, the game costs 20 bucks,
but it costs us $150 to get that thing to you."
Tim Ferriss: Holy shit.
Elan Lee: They're just like, "Well, I'll pay 10
of it, 'cause that's what shipping costs." Ugh.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: So it's really hard,
especially for new game designers.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Not that I'm
recommending people do this, but
presumably you can constrain your
geographic range on Kickstarter —
Elan Lee: We can.
Tim Ferriss: — so that you can minimize some of
the complexity here. I say that this is former
life, but I've shipped hundreds of thousands of
units with my first business, real business, which
is a sports nutrition company. The stuff that you
run into, especially if something has, in this
case, a reasonably high retail price, let's just
take Canada as a simple example, it gets shipped
to Canada. Okay, fine. You might say it only
costs, well, I'm throwing this number out, I don't
know what it is right now, but let's say it's $30.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, fine. So you figure
out a way to cover that. But then it lands
at their door and they say, "Well,
based on this price, that customer,
you need to pay us this additional cost —
Elan Lee: Oh, it is — yeah. Then,
if they don't pay it at the door, they cannot
accept the shipment. Now you know what you've
just made? You've just made an enemy,
because they're like, "What the fuck? I
already paid you for shipping, and now I had
to pay this additional," and it is endless.
It's endless. I hate shipping so much, so much.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So don't underestimate the
challenges of shipping, folks. You really
need to plan in advance for how you're
going to handle a lot of these eventualities.
Coming back to, now, this could be an antiquated
interview, but I was looking at some notes from
a past interview that you did, and I'm just going
to read here. Maybe it's changed, but "We have a
completely open-door policy when it comes to new
games. Designers pitch us games in person through
our website, via email, over Zoom every day."
You mentioned you're looking for games that
have a strong gameplay loop, simple enough,
et cetera, et cetera, some of which
we've discussed. Has that policy changed?
Elan Lee: Yeah, we had to.
Tim Ferriss: That seems like you could have
a tremendous amount of inbound — yeah, it had to,
right? Let's just say even at that time, though,
what are some of the other things
that you would be looking for,
because there must have been other tent poles
you were looking for if you're getting a lot
of unsolicited —
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — submissions.
Elan Lee: Well, I made this
really bad assumption, which was that people
who have game ideas have good game ideas.
So the things that we got
through the door were like,
"Hey, when I was a kid, we used to play this
game, and I don't remember what it was called,
but it involved three cards and you're trying
to collect four, so let's partner up on it."
I'm just like, "Okay, I can dismiss that one
email." But oh, my God, there's like 200 of
these a day and I don't have time to do my real
job. So what we had to do was hire a very talented
group of people to go out and get the games from
things like conventions, and there's a bunch of
inventor meetups and local meetups and things like
that. They filter them, they show me, honestly,
not that many anymore, maybe 10 a month, and
they already know what I'm looking for. I've said
no to so many of them that now they understand
exactly the sort of thing I'm looking for, and —
Tim Ferriss: What are some of those things?
Elan Lee: Yeah, it's a lot of the stuff we've
discussed, honestly, the core thing that I'm
always looking for is, are players entertaining
each other? That's the biggest fault I find in
almost everything presented to me is, "I made this
thing, it's really beautiful. The game is working
so hard to entertain the players." my response is
always like, "I don't care about those kinds of
games. I don't want a game to be in the spotlight.
I want the players to be in the spotlight. Stop
showing me games that are working this hard,"
and it's hard. It's really hard to find.
Tim Ferriss: It's a great example of focus
and positive constraints. I just want
to underscore that, at least from my
perspective as I hear you describing this,
because if your charter is to create great games,
you're fucked. It's just so broad. How
are you ever going to implement processes?
A follow-up question would be for me, at this
point, how many employees do you guys have?
Elan Lee: About 100.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Is it necessary to
go scouting for games? Is there a cost advantage
to doing that versus just whipping those geniuses
in house, feeding them Twizzlers and Coke and —
Elan Lee: Yeah, that's right, on a little hamster
wheel. Yeah. Okay. So 100 employees, let me
talk about what those employees are doing,
first of all, and why we went up to 100, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Elan Lee: Because we started with two or three,
and for a while we were outsourcing everything.
The components of the process of making a
game is not only, "Okay, we've got a design,
we've got a PDF. Here's all the art, here's
the rules, done. Send it off to manufacturing."
After that, we outsourced everything. We
outsourced the company that manufactured
them. We outsourced the company that would then
transport them from that plant to a warehouse. We
outsourced the sales channel. We outsourced the
marketing channels. We outsource just absolutely
everything. What Matt and I decided to do was to
just, "We've got this incredible opportunity, what
if we just tried to learn from this as much as we
possibly can? What if we just try to be experts at
everything just to see if we can, find the failure
points, hire smarter people to then fill those
gaps, but remove the reliance on external houses?"
So most of those 100 people are sales, marketing,
production, logistics, distribution, accounting,
legal, nothing to do with the actual creative side
of the company, because that we can do with a
very small team. It's all the other parts that
we decided to try ourselves, failed at it, hired
way smarter people, and then built those teams in
house. It helps us become masters in this field.
It helps us not have to do what other companies
do, and instead, blaze our own trail and figure
out, "Okay, we want to deliver..." Okay, perfect
example. The Exploding Kittens box is pretty
small. I want a huge piece of cardboard around it.
If we had a bunch of external
dependencies, we'd fall into the
same category with every other game. Nobody
gets treatment like that. That's impossible.
But now because we're dealing with Target and
Walmart directly, literally calling them on the
phone every day, and we deal directly with the
manufacturer, and we own that cardboard stock,
and we own the ink to put on that cardboard, now
we can have really interesting conversations with
them about, "What if we put this thing on your
shelves and we think it'll increase sales in this
way? What if we put a little secret component
in the corner and we will do a whole marketing
campaign about people finding that?" It's a
kind of conversation that nobody gets to have
in this industry. The only reason we get to
have it is because we are an end-to-end house
of which very few exist in the world.
Tim Ferriss: So end-to-end house has a
lot of vertical integration advantages, let's
say. Not risk-free, right? It takes fuel —
Elan Lee: 100 mouths to feed,
amongst other things, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, 100 mouths to
feed, and it takes fuel to grow.
For people who are unfamiliar, could you just
give us some milestones in terms of funding and
everything else? Because it's a rarity, as far
as I can tell, it's certainly not something that
I've come across a lot, and I'm relatively new
to the space, but this does seem to stand out.
Elan Lee: Yeah. So I've started a bunch of
startups. This is, I think, my fifth or sixth.
Every time the milestones are always like,
"Hey, we got our seed round or friends and
family round," and, "Hey, we just got this retail
channel. We just got this distribution deal."
For this one, it was really weird because for
the first few years of the company, we owned
100 percent of it and we had no one to answer to.
Instead of us going out saying, "Please, please,
please, sell our game," we had people knocking
on our door saying, "Please, please, let us sell
your game," so the milestones were really strange.
It wasn't, "We accomplished this thing." It was,
"We allowed somebody else to do the
thing that they were asking for,
to sell our game, to distribute our game,
to market our game." It went that way for
a long time. We had a bunch of people coming
in saying, "We want to invest in this thing,"
and we had this incredible luxury to say, "Money
is the one thing we just don't need. There's all
kinds of stuff we do need, but money is not it."
I remember one day, so this was maybe the first
big milestone, one day, this guy,
Peter Chernin came to our office —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I know the name —
Elan Lee: — a legend in Hollywood,
and he said, "I really want to invest in your
company." We said, "Yeah, no, thanks." He said,
"Hold on, just hear my pitch." He said, "You
are at the top of your game. You've done
all the things you should be doing. You've
grown as far as you should absolutely grow,
but the next step is to stop being a game company
and start being an intellectual property company.
What that means is TV shows and movies and theme
parks, and it turns out I'm probably the best in
the world at those things." Matt and I huddled
up and said, "Yeah, that's exactly right. This
is a really good point, one that we had never
considered. We don't know how to grow beyond
this point. We've done this as big as we can."
So we took an investment from The Chernin Group,
and that was a huge milestone for us.
We had never had partners. We'd never
given away anything, and suddenly we did. I would
say we spent 12 hours fretting that decision once
we signed the papers thinking, "Oh, what have we
done? Oh, no. There's another chef in the kitchen.
What does this mean?" Then Peter called us up
and he said, "Okay, if you could make a TV show,
who would you want to make it with? Who's
the top people in the world?" Both of us,
without hesitation, we're like, "Oh, well, Mike
Judge and Greg Daniels." Again, those two people
are worth Googling. That's Beavis and Butt-Head,
King of the Hill, The Office, Office Space,
like holy crap, the absolute best people in
the world, and we're like, "But, we know..."
He said, he's like, "Whoa, that's a really big
ask." We're like, "Yeah, we know, but you asked
who would be our number one choices, so there it
is." He said, "Okay, cool," and he got off the
phone. Next day, he called us up and he said, "Can
you come over to my house this afternoon? Well, I
really want to chat about this TV thing." We said,
"Sure." We went over to his house and sitting in
his living room on the couch were Greg Daniels
and Mike Judge. They looked at us and they said,
"Peter tells us you've got this really cool
game that you want to make a TV show out of,
and we should be the executive producers.
So can you please talk to us about it?"
It was at that point when Matt and I stopped —
Tim Ferriss: It's one of those "Spielberg
walks into your office" moments.
Elan Lee: Yeah, right? It's just these superpowers
that some people have, being able to align with
them and saying, "Look, together, the sum is
greater than the individual components." Peter's
superpower is that networking our superpowers,
we've got this really delightful IP, maybe this
is a chocolate and peanut butter moment. It turns
out, and it really was, right? So now —
Tim Ferriss:
Did you say chocolate and peanut butter?
Elan Lee: I did say chocolate and peanut butter.
Tim Ferriss: Getting all European on me.
Elan Lee: I know. All right. All right.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, please, continue. No, I like it.
Elan Lee: So the punchline here is now we have a
Netflix show in development and it's
executive produced by Greg Daniels,
Mike Judge, and Peter Chernin, and that's, holy
crap, we're this little startup that started in
my garage trying to raise $10,000. Now
we're at the absolute top of the game,
and that doesn't happen on our own. There's
no way we could have hit that on our own.
That was a huge milestone in us realizing,
"It's okay to give parts of this thing up
as long as we choose really wisely, as long as
it's people who share our vision and want to
make this thing bigger than we could on our own."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So for people who are curious,
The Chernin Group is TCG, tcg.co/portfolio.
We'll give you an idea of some of the
properties/companies and people they've
invested in. There are a lot of very good
ones. I see here Food52, which I know; also,
MeatEater, which I know because Steven Rinella
took me on my first ever hunt —
Elan Lee: Oh, that's awesome.
Tim Ferriss: I'm actually in one of the episodes
where we went to Alaska together. Exploding
Kittens is right next to MeatEater. Then you
have Hodinkee, which I know because my friend,
Kevin Rose, used to be the CEO; Barstool
Sports, and it goes on and on, Rooster Teeth,
which I have actually been to their offices.
I know those guys. I don't know them well, but
I've been there. Scopely, which I've actually been
looking at more closely recently. Hello Sunshine,
which some people might recognize, Reese
Witherspoon. They've had very nice outcomes
with Hello Sunshine, and it goes on and on and on.
So these guys, much like you, are good at focus.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: They have
very particular types of companies. Now, I
don't know if this is public, it might be,
but how much money did you end up raising?
Elan Lee: I don't know if it's public, but I don't
mind saying, we raised $40 million at that point.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Okay. So you raised $40
million. Now this is a world, not specific
to The Chernin Group, although I'm in some of
the same companies, but I've invested in a lot of
mostly seed stage or series A stage companies. But
with that money comes guidance, it comes health.
There's certain, also, expectations that they have
as professional investors.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: How does that play out?
Elan Lee: Okay. So first of all,
it's important to say that 40 million is still
sitting in our bank account because we just
didn't need it. So it's sitting there. But it
was important to have that as a signifier, right?
Tim Ferriss: No, and just to say, it's
not so much the money but once they have
a portion of the company their hope is
at some point to have a liquidity event.
Elan Lee: So that was really important for me to
understand, is that once you take on an investor,
it's not a matter of when you exit the company.
It's not a matter of if you exit the company,
it's now a matter of when you will exit
the company. And that took me a second to
understand, but what's really interesting, so I
remember, "Okay, now the Chernin group is on board
and now we have to have board meetings." That was
a new one for us and our very first board meeting,
so one of the partners at the Chernin Group is a
guy named Jesse Jacobs, one of the smartest people
I've ever met. And we sat down with him, we're
like, "Here's our first board meeting, here's
our presentation." And at the end of it, he said,
"That was the worst presentation I've ever seen."
And we're like, "Okay, well, we really did
our best. We clearly don't know what we're
doing." And so to their credit, we worked so
closely with him after that, he's like, "Okay,
you get a mulligan, we're going to do this thing
over, but let us train you. Let us work with you.
Let us hook you up with experts. Let us show
you other people's board decks, and you'll see
what a healthy company looks like, because you
two have been incredibly lucky, and you have to
plan on that not lasting forever." And they were
totally right. It was really important for us to
gain that new muscle and hire a new group of
people. We hired our first-ever accountant,
we hired a CFO. That was a very new thing for us.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. You didn't ha —
Elan Lee: No.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Well, look.
So wait a second. So you're
going in QuickBooks. I mean, what? What's going
on here if you guys don't have an accountant?
Elan Lee: Yeah. Well, I really love Google Sheets,
and so I literally wrote everything myself.
Tim Ferriss: Holy shit, man. Wow.
Elan Lee: That was our first five years.
Tim Ferriss: You must have had a lot
of free time for those first few years.
Elan Lee: I wouldn't call it free time. I
would say I had a lot of lack of sleep.
Tim Ferriss: That's what I'm
saying. I'm saying that sarcastically.
Elan Lee: Yeah. Fair enough. All right. Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. All right.
So you get your accountant.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So
you start getting systems in place.
Elan Lee: Start getting systems in place, and
we start figuring out, I think the Chernin group
and Jesse specifically, really started to lead
the charge in terms of like, "Okay, you want to be
good at everything. What does that actually mean?
Who do you have to hire? What are the milestones?"
I remember telling them, "We want to try
everything, and if we fail, we'll get help. That's
how we'll know what we can and can't do." And they
said, "Great, what does failure mean?" And I
thought, "Oh, shit. I haven't thought through
that definition." And they just forced discipline
on our company. They didn't impose anything. They
said, "Look, if you want to do it that way, we
will support you, but you haven't even defined
your terms yet. So let's start there." And it
was so helpful. It was so helpful. And yeah. God,
I love those guys. I've, like I said, lot of
startups, lot of investors. I have never sung
an investor's praise like that before because they
just held our hand. They're just like, "We support
you. We believe in you. Let's do this together."
Tim Ferriss: Do you provide equity incentives to
employees, or is it predominantly salary-based?
Elan Lee: We provide equity
to all employees. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. And feel free to
plead the fifth or whatever the legal is on this,
but I'm curious because I'm deeply interested in
how startup founders navigate decisions like
these. What percentage of the company did they
buy in their strategic investment? Or it could be
a range. I'm curious what the appetite looks like.
Because that also starts to inform the dynamics
that are at play after the investment closes.
Elan Lee: Yeah. So I'm specifically not
allowed to say, unfortunately, but what I —
Tim Ferriss: No problem.
Elan Lee: — but what I will say is,
what was very important to us is any terms of
any deal that we sign with anybody, we remain in
complete control of the company. We're interested
in help. We're not interested in having bosses.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So is it fair to say they might
approach it like a private equity investment, but
you want to ensure that you as equity
holders are in a position to still
retain control of the company?
Elan Lee: That's correct. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Okay. Well, so you have a tiger
by the tail, man. I won't push, I'm not going to
dig for more specifics, even though I'm super,
super interested personally. Because it's kind of
part of my education too. Let me ask you this —
Elan Lee: We can talk offline. How's that?
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
So let's say this. 10 years from now, 20 years
from now, at some point you'll be like, "You know
what? The seasons of my life, they are changing.
My daughter now has 20 more hit games
than I do. It's time to hang up my spurs."
When you have all the Skittles that money can buy,
or just you're satisfied. You've checked that box.
What do you think you'll spend your time
on? Let's just say you're no longer running
a company of this size.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. What do you think you'll do?
Elan Lee: I think for me, the thing that I'm most
interested in is — all right, let me phrase
this actually a different way. I think the
through line between all the companies I've
ever started and that have kept my interest
for the longest is empowering a community. And I
love doing that through story. I love doing that.
I really hate it when a spotlight's
on me. I get shy, I get weird and
uncomfortable, but I get — okay, I'm going to
tell you. My proudest moment so far has been,
I was at an airport and the flight was canceled
or it was delayed. The flight was delayed,
and it was so late at night that nobody could
get a new flight. And so we had this terminal
of all these grumpy people, everyone. They
were just getting on the phone trying to
find new things and getting turned down.
And we're all realized, we just have to
sit here for four hours and it sucks. And
everyone was complaining, and you could just,
there's this horrible negative energy. Except
for this one group of kids sitting on the floor
in a circle just laughing their asses off. And I
couldn't help but go over to them and look over
the shoulders and see what they were doing. And
sure enough, they were playing Exploding Kittens.
And it was like this unbelievably beautiful moment
for me. And whenever I tell people that story,
they always ask, "Did you tell them who you
were?" And the answer is, of course not.
That's the opposite of what I want.
I am so delighted that I could give them a toolset
to laugh with each other and have this horrible
experience transformed for them into a positive
one. And I do not want any credit for that at all.
I just want — I loved getting to witness that.
Let's set aside for a moment the fact that
here's this 40-something year old guy staring
at a bunch of teenagers at an airport. But for
me, it was a very nice moment. And so when I
think about what comes next, it's like, "I want
more of that." I want more of tool creation
to create those just little pockets of joy. And I
have a lot of ideas on maybe how to do it, but I
don't know which one is actually going to be it.
Tim Ferriss: So someone in my family worked at a
chocolate factory, and at one point — they went in
loving chocolate, and at some point they just had
too much chocolate, and it developed a different
connotation. So I'm curious how you have preserved
the desire and, I don't want to say novelty, but
the freshness of what you just described in face
of building a company that leads you to think
about games outside of having the experience
of sitting on the floor with your friends.
Elan Lee: I once took a skydiving class,
like a week-long skydiving course, and at the
end of it, I asked the instructor, I was like,
"Do you ever get bored of this?" And he said, "Do
you ever get bored of having sex?" And I thought,
that's exactly it. That's how I feel about
games. That's how I feel about this job. It's
not a thing with an expiration. It's a little
dopamine factory for me and the people who get
to have these experiences. I don't know how
you get bored of that. That's just eternal.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. All right. Well, I suppose yet
another vote for more games in people's lives.
So Elan, we've covered a lot of ground. We've
certainly gone in all sorts of different
directions. Is there anything else you would
like to add? People can find Exploding Kittens
at explodingkittens.com, and everywhere,
of course. And there are some social links,
but you're slowly ratcheting back on those, which
I think will be best for your mental health,
longevity, and pretty much everything in life. Is
there anything else that you would like to add?
Any requests of the audience, closing comments?
Elan Lee: Something I've been thinking
a lot about lately is I've become enamored with
partnerships. I really love — like, all the best
things that we're making now are collaborations
with somebody else way smarter than me, with
really interesting perspectives. We just made this
game with Penn Jillette from Penn and Teller, and
it's like, "What a amazing brain." I can't believe
I got access to that for a few months and got to
play with him. And what I thought about since then
is we as a company, Exploding Kittens, have this
really unique ability to say, "All right, smart
people out there, all right, people who have built
followings and built audiences. You know what's a
tough statement that you can't make on your own?
'I made a game.' Because it turns out it's really
hard to do." And I'm really proud to say that
we enable that. If you have a conversation
with me and we go down the path for a few
months, I can let you say that. And that's been
so satisfying lately. We're doing a few of those,
and it's just been, ah, it's so fun. For a guy
who gets very shy in social situations, using that
as my calling card, oh man, I am so set up for
success now. I wish I had thought of that earlier.
Tim Ferriss: So there are many different
types of dance partners. I mean,
Penn Jillette is amazing. Been on the podcast,
I was looking, it was I think 405. So several
hundred conversations ago on the podcast.
But how do you choose? What are your ideal
dance partners? What are the characteristics?
Elan Lee: It's really simple. It's people who love
their audiences, and maybe that sounds trite, but
so many of the people that I encounter do not. If
your audience is a tool for you to gain money,
if your audience is a means to an ends — not
interested at all. But for those who are like,
"I cannot help but entertain these people,
if I made nothing, I would still entertain
these people. If I had no stage or audience,
I would still do this exact same thing." Oh, I
love those people. They speak my language. We just
go on for hours. So that's my absolute favorite.
Tim Ferriss: So if somebody's listening and
they're like, "Hey, I think that's me."
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What do they do?
Elan Lee: They reach out, they write
to — let's see, what's the easiest one these days?
If you write to just support at Exploding Kittens,
that's like this really lovely group email
that goes out to a whole bunch of people. I
guarantee it'll make its way to me.
Tim Ferriss: All right. There you
go. You heard it. You heard it here.
All of those audience lovers out there,
and there are some good ones, I mean, there are
— I will agree with you that it is not everyone.
I would say it's actually probably even on
the smaller side. Like, if your audience
stops delivering any financial value to
you today, $0, can you derive from this
audience? Would you still engage? And I think
the answer for a very high percentage is no.
Elan Lee: That's absolutely right. I believe —
Tim Ferriss: The love is conditional upon
financial outcome, and I understand that if
you are making ends meet and having to focus on
paying rent and sending your kids to school and
so on. There are necessities in life. I understand
that. However, the cult of the influencer, I
find, to be a real amplifier of fun-house mirror
tendencies in human nature. I do think it's a very
distorting playing field in a lot of sense. Not to
take this off in a strange direction, but —
Elan Lee: You're going to start a whole
'nother hour here. All right, go ahead.
Tim Ferriss: I know. I was just going to
say that what I think folks need to be very
cautious of is, even if they start off with
the most sincere of intentions, if you are not
explicitly aware of and take steps to counter
the seduction of the algorithm, you will be
rewarded, vis-a-vis your audience, by more and
more extreme caricatures of yourself, and you will
therefore get propelled into becoming a mask. I've
seen this with dozens of people now, where they
used to be fairly moderate in their views, their
expression, their gesticulation, their volume,
and now they've painted themselves into a corner.
Sometimes they don't even realize it, where the
personality that their audience, in a sense,
and the platforms, have shaped them to be is what
they are. And that's a very precarious place to
be, especially, and you've had this experience, if
you're on a platform where you do not own direct
means of communicating with that audience
and if you have your organic reach throttled,
and suddenly 70 percent of your positive
reinforcement goes away, that is a risky business,
financially and psycho-emotionally.
Elan Lee: Psycho-emotionally,
especially. Yeah. Oh, Tim, so well phrased. I
cannot — the reason that I've dropped off of most
of social media, honestly, is because it feels
like that's a precarious place. It feels like it's
so easy to be there for the wrong reasons. It's so
easy to, by nature of attracting the wrong people,
let them shape who you are. Let them shape
the products that you make. Yeah. I don't
see the value in it anymore. And I'd rather just
surround myself with fun, loving, amazing people
who are nurturing and help me make amazing things.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Man. Hey, man, That is where
I hope to focus more in the upcoming year. And I
haven't had any social apps on my phone. Actually,
I've had one, I had reinstalled Twitter to be on
someone's Twitter spaces, but that'll probably
come off soon. Have not had any social apps
on my phone for about two years now, because
I do not believe that 99.999
percent of people out there
can overcome armies of data scientists and
extremely effective algorithms with self-control.
I don't think it's possible. Don't be that person
who's like, "I don't think I'll get addicted to
heroin. Let me just try it a few times," right?
Chances are you don't have an immunity bracelet.
Elan Lee: That's right. That's right.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Build, build,
build. All right, man. Well, this has
been really lovely. So nice to connect —
Elan Lee: Thank you. Such a delight.
Tim Ferriss: — and spend time together.
Elan Lee: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Really,
really enjoyed it. And I will just say to
everybody listening, as per usual, we will
have links to everything we discussed in the show
notes at tim.blog/podcast. E-L-A-N. There are no
other guests on this podcast with that name. So
if you go there and search, you will find this
episode in the show notes. And until next time,
just be a little bit kinder than is necessary,
build more, talk less, and have some fun,
folks. Get off of screens, play some games.
Thanks for tuning in.
Elan Lee: Thanks, Tim.